توجهنا الى قضاء الداقوق الذي تقطنه
الكثير من عائلات الكاكائين المرحلين من
كركوك هنا حيث يتعرض الكاكائيون في مدينه
كركوك للكثير من الضغوطات لترك منازلهم
والتره العشرات من العائلات خلال السنوات
السابقه الى ترك منازلها اما عن طريق
القوه او بقرار من المحكمه دون محاكمات
تذكر في هذا الحي تجد الكثير من
الكاكائيين المهجرين من منازلهم والذين
اجبروا تحت تهديد السلاح على المغادره
فرمان باراما كان احد الضحايا تم تفجير
منزله على رؤوس اطفاله وزوجته بسبب
اعتراضه على قرار اخلاء منزله لصالح شخص
اخر من انتماء اخر
جاءني اتصال هاتفي يخبرني ان هناك انفجارا
وقع بالقرب من بيتكم فاتصلت بالعائله ولم
يكن هناك جواب وكنت حينها في مدينه اربيل
فاقفلت راجعين وانا في السياره جاءني خبر
عبر الهاتف بان عائلتي واطفالي تحت حط
حطام البيت وان فرقه الدفاع المدني متجهه
الى المكان لاخراجهم وحين وصلت وتوجهت الى
المستشفى لانهم اخبروني انه تم نقلهم الى
هناك كان الانفجار عنيفا وبعضهم قال ان
صوته وصل الى مدينه كركوك التي تبعد نحو
40 كم عند قوق زوجتي اصيبت وجروح شديده
وطفلي تم اخراجه بعد ساعتين من تحت الحطام
انا متاكد انا من فعل ذلك هي الملكيه لان
المنطقه فيها عدد من المسؤولين والمنطقه
ذات حراسه مشدده من قبل عناصر تلك ومعظم
العناصر هم من المليليات التي بالقانون
عرض الحائط
شقداري
ميليشيافاندون كوشي حارتي حدثت عمليه قتل
وقتال واختطاف استهدفت المواطنين
الككائيين فمثلا منذ عام 2003 حتى نهايه
عام 2007 تركت 100 عائله كانت تسكن في قلب
مدينه كركوك في حي العروبه دورها نتيجه
لهذه العمليات بعضها توجهها الى اقليم
كردستان والبعض الاخر الى مناطق اخرى ووفق
الاحصائيه التي قامت بها منظمه مصر وحتى
هذه الساعه التي اتكلم فيها معكم هي مقتل
254 كاكائيا على يد المجموعات الارهابيه
وتعرضت قرى الكاكائيين في الموصل وكركوك
لهجمه جمال